what do you think about porn
it's nice I like it okay you like it yes
uh what effect do you think it has on
society
uh it's been like probably reduces rates
of rape because like really horny men
get an outlet that's not a real life
woman Okay so
what about like the um
I mean like I said I finished reading
Brave New World like the over
sexualization
does it does it increase like
the sexualization society that's not
into a degree it's not good or is this
is good like the
are really does it alter
in a negative Direction our relationship
with sex
ah it's unclear like it might
I don't know how to evaluate this thing
right because this is like one of those
really charged things where like I kind
of don't trust anybody's arguments on it
because it's too charged
um but like there's another question
which is like is it a net positive or
net negative yeah like it's possible
that it might be like a net negative
four specifically our relationship to
sex but like a net positive overall in
general
I'm not sure but I think my guess is
that in general it's better to let
people do the thing that feels good to
them and then the environment will
naturally modify to fit this thing and
then if we have more needs in response
to that then we're going to figure out a
way to take care of those needs so if
you're watching a bunch of porn and this
makes you like not want to go have sex
with women then we're gonna have to like
change the way that we like experience
IRL connection
um to compete with porn yeah which seems
like a natural evolution of like the
civilizational cycle like I'm
pro-natural Evolution and like instead
of trying to stop at things that people
wanted to actually figure out how to
integrate that and like find a more
healthy outlet but you have to then be
first honest with the effects that porn
has so like is it a negative thing is it
a positive thing on in real life
sex interaction
you know you're going to have that more
and more with
whether like
like porn and VR or maybe porn AI porn
yeah
like is that is that a bad thing like
what if porn with AI
or even like in physical space like sex
robots like what if that's more
pleasurable in a bunch of different
dimensions than with other humans then
we should figure out artificial wombs I
don't know
like how important is sex for society I
guess with between two humans yeah I
mean like we're having less sex than
making fewer babies and that seems like
probably not great
uh yeah right with the babies one
yeah but the babies there's probably
artificial ways to have babies that we
can figure out yeah but then how
important it sex to be human I guess sex
with other humans like we're gonna have
to figure that out in the century
yeah I don't know what it means to like
be human I'm I'm pretty on the per the
transhumanist side of things I'm like
happy to stop being human
so you're okay if like the centuries the
last time will be something like these
biological bags of meat that we are
let's become something new and cooler
even though that thing would be way
cooler than you well I would like to I
mean I'm hoping that we get to be
immortal
ah it'll take you along for the ride
that's what I'm hoping are you like you
know clone my I would like to do
cryonics you get Frozen when you die